[Applaudissements]
alors non bébé
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
[Musique]
forme on peut pas dire princesse ça
devient présente-toi toute seule c'est
moi qui m'en occupe c'est bon tout est
sous contrôle je te fais confiance
donc c'est moi qui suis chargé d'essayer
de vous raconter l'histoire de cette
princesse alors comme dans tous les
contes de fées l'histoire par commence
par il était une fois il était une fois
à Karachi la rencontre improbable d'un
prince indien et d'une jeune femme Russe
très belle fille d'un officier de la
marine du tsar et d'une pianiste
elle-même fut lieutenant dans l'armée
française pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors ils se rencontrent dans
une ambassade il tombe éperdument
amoureux et c'est un conte de fée il se
marièrent et eurent
un enfant
c'est déjà pas mal
c'est ainsi que notre princesse aînée
donc on continue l'histoire il était une
fin une il était une fois une princesse
Russo pakistanaise
on pourrait presque pitcher un film pour
Hollywood il était une fois cette
princesse on pourrait imaginer la
Gaumont en association avec Pathé cinéma
présente la merveilleuse histoire de
Zarina sauf que le conte de fées ne va
pas exactement se passer comme prévu en
fait cette petite fille est la cible de
la haine des hommes
et ce couple mixte dans ce Pakistan des
années 50 attire la pire des violences
quand je vous dis qu'elle attire la pire
des violences ça va jusqu'à la
lapidation de sa mère alors que la
petite princesse n'a que trois ans
alors sa maman va miraculeusement
miraculeusement s'en sortir
mais évidemment se souvenir va être
traumatisant et va être également
fondateur dans dans l'histoire de cette
petite fille elle écrira ensuite un
roman un roman vrai de sa vie où elle
parlera de cet épisode et je me permets
de partager ce passage
lorsque ma mère s'est relevée la
dislocation s'est achevée la lapidation
avait échoué mais on murmurait que la
prochaine serait fatal et que j'en
serais la cible j'étais le fruit du
péché de cet homme musulman qui devait
continuer sa mission et de cette femme
qui ont qu'on avait voulu tuer parce que
si blanche si différente et si
chrétienne
j'étais l'impardonnable enfant du
premier couple mixte de ce jeune pays
mixte ce mot je l'ai souvent entendu
j'avais alors demandé à Mariam mixte
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire elle
était perplexe et a tenté de m'expliquer
nous étions devant des parters fleuries
elle a désigné une rose très claire d'un
jaune pastel puis un peu plus loin une
autre fleur de Volubis avec sa clochette
mauve tu vois ces deux fleurs elles sont
toutes les deux des fleurs et pourtant
elle pousse chacune sur un arbre très
différent elles ne sont pas de la même
famille des fleurs si on les mariés elle
formerait un couple mixte
mais on ne peut pas les marier car elles
ne sont pas de la même famille et elles
ne pourraient pas engendrer d'autres
fleurs ou alors même si elle venait à
engendrer une troisième fleur celle-ci
serait une anomalie et elle ne pourrait
pas survivre survivre la nature est
ainsi faite elle parlait à voix basse
comme si ma question était honteuse
alors je n'ai pas poursuivi pour pas la
gêner néanmoins mes pensées s'agitaient
mon père et ma mère étaient un couple
mixte il n'était pas de la même famille
et il n'avait pas grandi sur le même
arbre ni sur la même terre mais il
m'avait engendré moi
et même si j'étais une anomalie je me
sentais bien capable de survivre sauf si
ont décidé de me tuer comme on avait
tenté de le faire avec ma mère la nature
est-elle ainsi faite la nature humaine
alors on a laissé la petite fille à
Karachi mais sa mère va décider de
partir de sortir la petite du pays pour
aller à Tunis ce sera leur premier exil
et puis la vie va reprendre sa mère va
rencontrer un homme avec lequel elle va
se remarier il s'avéra que cet homme est
un ancien nazi et va faire subir à notre
princesse le pire des outrages
donc à ce stade quand elle me raconte
ses épisodes et ce ne sont que des
épisodes des trois tomes du roman
qu'elle a écrit sur sa vie une des
questions que je lui ai posé c'est
Zarina comment on fait comment on fait
pour s'en sortir comment on fait pour
dépasser la haine
et elle me répond elle me dit je me suis
accrochée à une étoile et je ne l'ai
jamais lâché
ok l'étoile aussi on va s'accrocher à
cette étoile c'est quoi cette étoile
Zarina mais c'est la création regarde
étonne toi laisse-toi porter par la
beauté du monde tout n'est que création
et tout n'est que beauté pour elle quand
l'homme créé il sort de sa de sa
violence il sort de sa frustration et il
s'éloigne de sa blessure
pour elle la création est une voie vers
la guérison d'ailleurs elle dit que
l'art-thérapie c'est un pléonasme qui
qui ne fait que répéter à un concept qui
est déjà associé
et donc sa vie va être émaillée de
création elle va être aussi émaillée de
rencontres
surprenante elle va croiser Adenauer
elle va croiser Orson Welles et aussi
Franco
elle va côtoyer des tas d'artistes des
peintres des musiciens des auteurs
des danseurs et elle-même va faire de sa
vie évidemment un outil de création
aujourd'hui elle est écrivaine
philosophe metteur en scène comédienne
et elle anime des ateliers dans des pays
en guerre elle anime des ateliers aussi
dans des quartiers difficiles des zones
de conflits
elle a fait de son métier vraiment la
création mais elle est également engagée
dans d'autres combats elle est engagée
pour le combat dans le combat pour les
droits de l'enfant et en 2005 elle a
même été nommée pour le prix Nobel de la
paix
alors à ce stade je pense que vous en
pensez moi je pense qu'on peut laisser
tomber Hollywood et
contactez directement Netflix on fera
plusieurs épisodes ce sera plus simple
d'ailleurs c'est un des nombreux
dossiers sur lequel elle travaille de
faire une série de sur sa vie
et elle a un autre grand projet aussi
j'ai oublié de passer les slides vous
avez remarqué donc regardez vite
son projet actuel c'est de construire si
une nouvelle casquette puisqu'elle a une
casquette de chef de chantier maître
d'oeuvre elle est en train de construire
une cité de solidaire d'accueil où elle
projette de recevoir chez elle donc à
Mirabel en Ardèche en Ardèche une cité
où elle recevrait des artistes des
migrants mais toute personne qui aura
envie de se révéler à travers la
création et l'art
voilà donc vous comprenez pourquoi
c'était extrêmement compliqué de la
présenter tant elle a de multiples
casquettes et sa vie c'est vraiment
l'antithèse de la synthèse et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
essayé de résumer sa vie pour introduire
son propos mais le mieux c'est de
l'accueillir je vous demande
d'accueillir la grande Zarina Cannes
[Applaudissements]